Hey Youtubers it's Charlie! So a lot of you
guys asked for Star Wars Rebels video so this
is going to be all about the siege of Lothal
technically it's like the first episode of
season two and the rest of the season won't
air till October so it's it's a little bit
where there might've been some confusion about
that that might seem where they decided to
drop it during the summer but it is probably
just because they want to get people psyched
up about season to and and I felt like you
were does a great episode so just careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen it yet lesser
with top-five moments starting with the ghost
fighting with Phoenix quadrant in the rebellion
all through season one Kanan me this huge
deal about staying out of the fight and a
lot of the ark of this episode was him realizing
that you know you can't stay out completely
it's in their DNA that they want to help people
make the galaxy a better place so so the ghost
crew help remind him of that and that's what
the rebellion is all about do not fight your
destiny Kanan so season to roll in heavy on
the rebellion which you think is a really
good answer to a lot of the complaints in
season one it was just like a series of misadventures
from week to week with you know like up a
recurring cast of villains now it's more like
the ghost going up against the full might
of the Empire with the rebellion the stakes
have appropriately risen season one wasn't
bad or anything like that but I feel like
it was harder to take it seriously when they
were kind like often this little bubble to
the side of the war between the rebellion
and the Empire they were going to try and
help people but we have nothing to do with
the rebellion one of the most interesting
aspects of the Star Wars universe opening
the episode mid space battle did not hurt
things either this is kind of like a special
episodes so don't expect that much action
every single week but there will be a lot
more of them engage in the Empire you know
q. rebel scum rather than them constantly
trying to avoid them onto number four a much
more complex empire part of the ark of this
episode totally would not have worked if people
inside the Empire were not fallible not everybody
has a total hard on for subjugating the galaxy
so Darth Vader's able to play that Imperial
officer against the rebellion he predicts
she's going to defect and uses it is an opportunity
to fall the breadcrumb trail back to the rebellion
and they had the balls to kill or die was
actually a really great moment in the episode
is much you can criticize children's television
for for seemingly not having any stakes is
because all we don't want it to be too violent
because children watch it they went ahead
and kill that officer unit even if it was
in a bloodless way there's a weird thing about
TV violence and blood it even happens like
on the flash on the CW shows what one of the
writers was saying how they had to dialback
some of the violence because it was too much
blood I feel like I'm letting Rebels go in
this direction it is going to do like to address
dumbs storm troopers that's always been a
big criticism that like Imperial officers
storm troopers very dumb people the expanded
universe goes into it a lot but you know you
I guess you can consider a can anymore because
they did changed everything but it is really
hard to get into the Imperial Academy even
even to be like a normal storm trooper it's
a getting into Harvard or Yale so why are
storm troopers always so dumb is really funny
thing to think about you know really is just
like they need someone for the heroes to be
able to be whenever their hand is a loss like
Darth Vader he's going to be unbeatable he's
was going to like you know stomp the crap
out of them so in some way the heroes need
to have a when and unfortunately the lowest
people in the totem pole are storm troopers
so if you ever wondered why storm troopers
go down so fast whether so disposable it's
because there always has to be like a villain
that's super tough to beat and then a villain
that's not so tough to beat the thing that
really interested me about this Imperial officer
though is the idea that your imperials have
complicated motivations to it is we spent
so much time with the heroes you you don't
get to develop a lot of those villain characters
we spent a lot of time with the inquisitor
last season but he still felt like a relatively
cardboard villain hopefully this new inquisitor
will be more complex onto number three though
deep dive inside the rebellion it really doesn't
become apparent until much later in the episode
when they meet is soak up on the rebel ship
that that there like they're inside the rebellion
even though the ship got blown up by I know
that they made it seem like they crush the
rebellion the imperials role patting themselves
in the back after Darth Vader blew them up
there is more to the rebellion then just the
people at that battle but never really feels
like they're part of this larger fight the
the like a small piece in the puzzle the did
a good job a slippery get in but they did
imply that there are several high ranking
people in the Empire which ships resources
power they just aren't quite ready to step
out into the light and declare for the rebellion
so Ismay ships is just got blown up like they'll
be able to get more Monmouth mama Bail Organa
both very big Imperial senators before they
founded the rebellion but speaking of big
people onto number two the will of Vader so
we just have to say how awesome it is that
they let Darth Vader out to play Disney doesn't
let that happen very often that was always
one of the big questions when the series was
announced wait you away before season one
like is Darth Vader going to be part of this
know will why should I watch and then but
even if it's only for a little bit we get
to watch them ter shit up for an hour if his
character design seemed a little bit where
TV if you look a little strange like the helmet
the tunic it's because it's meant to reflect
the old school Ralph McQuarrie concept art
just just like everything else in Rebels Rebels
is a series is much more informed by Ralph
Pecora's concept art he serves like two really
big roles in the narrative like he is and
just here for sightseeing one on the surface
he he there to kick the crap out of the rebellion
he manipulates the crew the ghost all the
the characters in the episode to get at them
that the ultimate goal crushing the rebellion
that's why we didn't seem as much in season
one because the code because we were falling
the crew the ghost they were really part of
the rebellion so Darth Vader had no reason
to go after them any any didn't know about
the Jedi's second big role is to change the
tone of the Jedi arc this season become a
level you you the story about the crew the
ghost coming together fighting the Empire
on another level you have Ezra training to
become a Jedi Knight think about the battle
they had with Darth Vader you just the way
he fights is very different from the inquisitor
season one was all about their skill as a
Jedi that's why think they gave that crazy
double bladed spinning saber was all about
train to fight better see you can be the really
awesome fighter the problem is is that you're
never going to be Darth Vader in a lifesaver
fight physically he's too strong and his will
is too powerful so you know unless you names
like Luke Skywalker you're done for the only
way to be Vader is to out match his will and
in his will is like the most powerful thing
in the Star Wars universe next to the will
of the Emperor maybe Darth Vader is not a
problem that punching is going to solve it
was fun to see them use some familiar tricks
like you're making people think they've escaped
and playing their weaknesses against them
like burning Tark in town doesn't this look
familiar Ahsoka sensing Vader probably my
favorite twist in the episode I I don't know
how many episodes Ahsoka is going to be in
but it seems like she's pretty much part of
the crew the ghost now she very clearly lied
to Kanan when she's like I don't know who
was behind the mask I'm I'm not sure she definitely
knew that that was Anakin Skywalker he sensed
it was her immediately Darth Vader immediately
tells the Emperor yet that was deftly my apprentice
hopefully they'll follow up on that arc this
season I have feel like they wouldn't of set
that up if they weren't intending to but finally
my number one moment the new inquisitor so
Vader and the Emperor teased this new villain
we haven't met yet who's going to be like
the big bad of season two one of the big things
about successive seasons is in presenting
new challenges and villains that fit with
that but the skills you developed to overcome
practical problems like helping the rebellion
also help you fight the villain so the villain
should be fundamentally different from the
season one inquisitor. Movie question view
guys what is your favorite moment from the
episode and you know if you didn't really
watch season one that much did this episode
convince you to watch season two like will
you be watching October when it comes I really
do feel like they were trying to push people's
buttons like here look at all the sauce and
stuff don't forget Rebels is coming back in
October there will actually be some Star Wars
stuff it, caught in a couple weeks it so I
feel like the there is trying to carry the
momentum into the fall like they did is they
don't want you to forget that this is a series
one of the really redeeming things the episode
that I was really happy to see what was the
idea that the Empire is interested in loath
all first sinister reasons I guess I just
some random place that we keep going back
to season one really didn't explain why we
were spending so much time there is like big
galaxy many many plans to go to why do we
keep going back to this one planet now we
know there's something special about it that
will learn about over the course of season
two as a season premiere this is definitely
a Soliday episode but will see how the rest
of the season goes sometimes it's hard to
remember that a lot of times season one of
any show is the writers just trying to figure
the characters out see get to season to season
three in the show really starts to get interesting
that used to be a lot easier to do now now
TV so competitive that like of the shows and
super popular in the first season they'll
cancel it off see you never get that chance
so if you're on the fence about rebel season
one I feel like season two's going to be a
lot more fun I can't promise that all of be
able to make weekly videos for it but I'll
definitely be watching In case you guys haven't
seen it I just posted a video explaining how
resurrection works on game of thrones you
can click here to learn all about that and
you can click here to learn all about the
multi-verse on the flash season two thank
you so much for watching, everybody High Five
and I'll see you guys tonight!